economía en directo América de Francia
24 Daniela Blandón con nosotros en el
estudio Daniela vamos a iniciar hablando
del mercado financiero mundial Porque
mira en una sola dirección Así es Raúl
le adivine cuál es esa cuál es esa
dirección
Hoy es el segundo día de reunión de la
reserva Federal el mes pasado el mismo
dijeron Powell que es el presidente de
la reserva Federal lo anticipó dijo que
iban a reducir la inflación así Eso
traerá algo de dolor para los
consumidores y es posible que ese
anticipo se haya se haga realidad hoy si
el banco eleva su tasa de interés en 75
puntos básicos esto por tercer mes
consecutivo para que usted se haga una
idea de la dimensión Raúl las tasas
apenas hace unos meses estaban entre el
0% y el 0,25% en Estados Unidos ahora es
posible que lleguen a entre 3% y 3,25%
este es su nivel más alto en 14 años y
lo que hace es como siempre lo decimos
aumentar drásticamente los costos
hipotecas y en general de todos los
préstamos comerciales bueno Daniela y en
el mundo hay más riqueza por el dinero
sigue como siempre concentrado en unos
pocos Claro que sí pero antes de eso
Raúl quiero hablarles rápidamente de
cómo amanecieron los mercados
ha marcado diferentes tendencias según
la región en Estados Unidos Wall Street
cerró el martes con pérdidas destacamos
por supuesto la acción de Ford que
perdió
12,32% su caída diaria más profunda en
una década después de reconocer que los
costos relacionados con la inflación
pueden superar los mil millones de
dólares este trimestre y que las
entregas van a seguir retrasadas por la
escasez de chips y otras piezas esto
para quienes quieran conseguir carro por
estos días las bolsas europeas se mueven
con mucha cautela siguiendo de cerca el
anuncio del presidente ruso Vladimir
Putin de una movilización militar
parcial esto perjudica la confianza en
un mercado que ya de por sí está muy
nervioso por esta política agresiva de
la reserva federal y las pérdidas y se
vieron en Asia con sus principales
índices cayendo entre el 1 y el 2% ahora
Entonces ahora sí hablemos entonces Dani
de la concentración de la riqueza como
siempre unos pocos Bueno hay un informe
al que publica anualmente el banco
Credit que dice que en 2021 la riqueza
en el mundo creció 9,8% se ubica en 463
billones de dólares millones de millones
de ese total casi la mitad está en manos
de un 1% de la población y se ha
concentrado en solamente dos países
Estados Unidos que representa la mitad
del total de esa riqueza y China una
cuarta parte ahora la riqueza media por
adulto y usted me dirá si está dentro de
ese Rango está calculada en casi 88 mil
dólares
Bueno ahora le voy a hablar de los
hallazgos del informe en el mundo hay
alrededor de 5.500 millones de adultos
la cifra de millonarios es decir
aquellos que tienen una fortuna más de
un millón de dólares súper a los 62
millones otros 627 millones de adultos
tienen entre 100.000 y un millón de
dólares
1800 millones de adultos son clase media
y la base de la pirámide o sea aquellos
con fortunas de menos de 10 mil dólares
llega casi a los 2.000 900 millones otro
dato adicional de toda esa riqueza
mundial menos del 3% está en América
Latina se explica porque nosotros no
estamos ahí también bueno Daniela pues
es algo común no un problema común no
individual Reino Unido también limitará
Los costos de los mayoristas de
Electricidad y gas para las empresas
esto también tiene que ver por supuesto
con la guerra en Ucrania de cara al
invierno de todo pues mire funciona de
la siguiente manera este incentivo los
precios mayoristas de la electricidad
tendrán un tope de alrededor de 211
libras que son como 239 dólares por
megavatio hora y el gas va a tener un
límite de 75 libras por megavatio hora
Esto en los próximos seis meses En
comparación con lo que se tiene previsto
de 600 libras y 180 libras
respectivamente o sea casi el triple se
están rebajando gran parte la medida
regirá a partir del primero de octubre y
ayudará a aliviar la presión de Los
crecientes costos de la energía pero
también suma un gasto más al gobierno
que ya van rápidamente este
endeudamiento la ocd ya ha salido a
criticar este tipo de subvenciones hoy
escuchamos que dijo la primera ministra
listres
sabemos que las empresas están muy
preocupadas por el nivel de sus facturas
de energía por eso estamos implementando
un esquema que será equivalente al de
los hogares para asegurarnos de que las
compañías puedan superar el invierno
vamos a revisarlo después de seis meses
nos aseguraremos de que los negocios más
vulnerables como pops o tiendas
continúen recibiendo ayuda después de
eso
Dani la guerra en Ucrania como sabemos
Todavía está en curso pero un icono
volvió a que es la capital ucraniana Sí
señor
Pues los residentes de la capital
ucraniana dicen que este restaurante se
ha convertido en un símbolo de
normalidad en tiempos difíciles la
compañía anunció la reapertura de tres
sucursales para domicilio algunos
lugareños estaban tan ansiosos por tener
en sus manos esta tradicional comida
rápida estadounidense que inclusive
hicieron cola durante horas para poder
conseguirla
para algunos es solo un paquete de papas
fritas pero este residente de la capital
ucraniana ha estado esperando este
momento Durante meses
esa felicidad pura felicidad
McDonald's había estado cerrado desde el
comienzo de la guerra y recientemente
tres sucursales de la cadena de comida
rápida en kiev han reabierto para
domicilio Mientras tanto algunos
clientes comenzaron a hacer sus pedidos
desde el día anterior
creo que no voy a descansar hoy
algunos clientes incluso esperaron junto
a su repartidores para recoger su pedido
Tan pronto como estuviera listo la
demanda era tan alta que una aplicación
local de entrega de comida tuvo que
Cancelar sus pedidos y dejó de aceptar
nuevos para muchos ucranianos McDonald's
es señal de que la vida normal está
regresando a la ciudad
realmente me gustaría olvidarme de la
guerra y recordar cómo se sentían las
cosas antes de la invasión rusa a gran
escala personal simboliza esa época
anterior a la guerra
McDonald dijo que planea abrir otros
siete restaurantes en kief el próximo
mes nunca dejó de pagar a sus empleados
en sus más de 100 sucursales ucranianas
a pesar de los cierres pero en Rusia El
gigante de la comida rápida vendió sus
operaciones al empresario
multimillonario Alexander los más de 800
antiguos restaurantes ahora han sido
rebautizados como sabroso y punto tienen
hamburguesas y papas fritas pero los
equivalentes rusos del icónico big Mac o
mcflurry están fuera del menú
le dio hambre
está agua en la boca cifra el día Dani
79 millones de euros veíamos imágenes de
globo ahí en Ucrania pues mire la esta
79 millones son la multa que impuso el
Ministerio de trabajo de España a
deliver Hero que también es conocida
como globo es esta misma franquicia por
violar una ley que exige que las
empresas de entrega de alimentos
contraten formalmente a sus
domiciliarios y que no sean autónomos
como venían siendo el gobierno dice que
la compañía se ha negado a otorgar
contratos laborales a más de 10.600
motociclistas en la segunda y tercera
ciudad es más grandes del país que son
Barcelona y Valencia esto Desde que la
ley entró en vigencia el año pasado Dani
como siempre Gracias por toda la
información económica más adelante más
economía nos vemos a las 8:45 hora
Bogotá
y bueno ahora saludamos a Luis Méndez sé
que tiene toda la información depo